well I was loving the flow like I didn't
realize all that was captured and I'm
Langston and this is Earth's Mightiest
show brought to you by Walmart yeah
we're gonna be talking about all of the
coolest stuff in the Marvel Universe
that you are hardcore Fanning about and
we have so much stuff on the show this
week first off we've got our hands on
the home release version of Marvel
Studios black panther hey hey and we're
cracking it open to bring you
never-before-seen extras yeah oh that's
not all up oh yay actress Danai gurira
is gonna open up about one of her
favorite moments from on set that you
didn't see in the movie black bear plus
more Marvel Studios magic as Ryan Pineau
goes heads to Atlanta Georgia for a
behind-the-scenes weapons work and with
Marvel Studios Avengers infinity war in
theaters now I'm gonna take to the
streets to see how much our fans know
about some of our most beloved MCU
characters but first we got to give a
shout out to all of you fans who are
resisting the urge to spoil Marvel
Studios Avengers infinity hey listen up
ears open remember hashtag Thanos
demands your silence I know that you
guys want to talk about it but we really
appreciate the folks who are keeping it
off of social media so that everybody
can have the same exciting experience
yes thank you all in an upward yes don't
spoil stuff yeah yeah yeah take that
world oh and also Marvel Studios by
Panther was still in theaters at the
same time that this film came out so you
could see two Marvel films at the same
time and that hasn't happened since the
very beginning of the MCU
ping-pong back and forth between Wakanda
and Venice studios black panther
oh we've got the DVD extras we've got
the goodness from gray and we're gonna
share with you an exclusive clip you
can't see this anywhere else until you
get the film it's an amazing clip that's
a conversation between the Black Panther
film creators Ryan Coogler Namor and Joe
Robert Cole and comic book writers Dunn
McGregor Christopher priest and Todd
Ahoskie Coates
the 1970s the first Black Panther
service was being done
you weren't obviously a lot of black
characters pop culture was not where it
is now as you guys doing this from I
wish we had the backing in terms of
people believing in the project they
felt they would give me a book that was
going to die the Black Panther wasn't an
important catch but the reason that we
got to do what we did was because they
didn't have time to read those books
they could I'll do it I think about
three four issues in and then say hey
wait a minute but it was too late it's
already a novel and that I could do it
what made it unique was just the idea at
the time not only was this a black
superhero and it was kind of a shock
when he's pulls off his mask and reveals
himself to be an African King but he's
also rich very smart yeah the king of a
kingdom and he single-handedly defeats
Marvel's premier family group Fantastic
Four and this was all being done and
delivered to a largely white and male
audience at the time so it was kind of a
shock wave in a sense and delivered at a
time of civil unrest during the growth
of the civil rights movement and it just
showed what a progressive thinker Stan
was and still is to this day make sure
to pick up Marvel Studios black panther
on digital download may 8th or on
blu-ray and DVD may 15th you got a
little misty
watching that honestly I mean that's an
amazing room of really prolific creators
and just hearing them talk about the
cultural relevance of the character and
Stan it's just really beautiful speaking
of Stan Lee you got to talk to Stan Lee
at the Avengers infinity war premiere
which is amazing I was standing right
behind you
why'd I yeah you worried I was sitting
right behind ya I knew 95 years old
still on the red carpet still doing
cameos and still being part of Marvel
Cinematic you still the man still Stan
the man it's so awesome
oh and we got to talk about this from
Marvel Studios but I got to talk to you
also deny Guerrera who plays McCoy the
general of the doorman ashay and she
told me some of her
favorite behind-the-scenes moments that
you guys have never gotten to see check
it out oh well there's so many I think
what was really fun was you know we've
talked about it a bit here and there but
when we were all in the Wakanda Falls
scene it was just so many people dressed
so beautifully and you know just
celebrating this country and this moment
of Coronation and then we had so many
amazing drummers on set and you know one
of them they just started to to rock out
to like the beat of drop it like it's
hot and like you I mean Peter went on
and on about that and the junket but it
was just such a fun moment III hope you
guys get to see that that was really fun
and of course latisha
freestyling and and you know me being
behind her like just really tight man
exactly what I was loving the flow like
I didn't realize all that was captured
then I saw the PETA's limo I'll take of
it I was like okay I look like the geek
enjoying or enjoying some good rap
behind this this little rap legend that
was born on that set but that was really
fun
latisha riot freestyle rapping yes
please
two please yes I'm also tiny legend
could be a great rap yeah hashtag County
legend I like that I sign off I mean I
would have loved to have been on
warriors Falls which by the way fun fact
is a practical set that's a bill set a
huge set piece that takes up a very
large lot and I believe Atlanta Georgia
where they do a lot of their filming I
would like to go I would like to go to
warriors ville and also another cool
thing props props I love props
our very own right vanagas got his hands
on the props they bring Marvel Studios
Avengers infinity ward of life so watch
that holy crap y'all I'm Ryan pentose
aka Marvel's agent M and I am here at
Pinewood Studios in the Marvel Studios
prop warehouse with none other than the
master of props himself Russell Bobbitt
yeah welcome
[Music]
we're here in this warehouse as props
warehouse but it's more than a warehouse
it's more than just props it's this is
art this is history can you show us some
of this amazing stuff yeah sure I can
Kimura sword is interesting in that it
sits in her holster small and she whips
it and it becomes big so my job is to
provide the small one for the holster
provide the large one once it's
completely out and then in
post-production they grow it and they
take over in between so I do the start
and the finish and they do everything in
between yeah this is an aluminum one
that's lightweight enough to to wield
and with Zoey's stature we figured out
the right length and the right weight so
that she can wield it like you know a
person that's been using this for years
and years dr. Strange's I was made by
Barry Gibbs on the first Doctor Strange
and then we inherited it on infinity war
and a fascinating part of this whole
thing is this lanyard this lanyard is is
made from about seven or eight pieces of
leather that are hand twisted and
braided for hours and hours a machine
can't do this so this was all done
in-house by one of our what I would call
an artist 100 and and each one matches
so that she had to make several of them
and and they all just look beautiful and
they have the perfect amount of aging
and and and everything so that when we
put a brand-new piece on cumberbatch he
doesn't know it's any different these
are the the real ones not rubber the
carbon fiber on here is a task in itself
it's a very challenging little prop to
make and then we take and do like heat
signature stuff here you can see the
purple and the you know almost the
colors of the rainbow in there to show
that this thing it gets up to 2,000
3,000 degrees Kelvin you know like we
really tell we go far to tell that story
James Gunn is a brilliant filmmaker and
really into detail and he just hits this
hard he's got this great mind for
telling a story and he tells the story
with every single piece
the film which I appreciate and it
really pushes us for excellence in every
problem there was another thing about
this weapon is James wanted which never
happened in Guardians 1 and Guardians 2
he wanted to have a reload and there was
never a reload or a cartridge built into
this gun and so then you thought well it
doesn't it's not a projectile gun so
it's not like a cartridge you'd see on a
pistol or a machine gun so I created
this tube but we made this tube which
would be a gas tube that that goes in
here and that's his reload so he pulls
one out throws it and puts a new one in
kind of cool supercollider cool yeah I
mean if you got to think of something on
the fly that's not bad I've never seen
that I don't never ever seen that detail
so neat yeah it was quick in the movie
so you go don't blink awesome
my favorite thing is Ryan Pitts nagas
just gently creeping sector yeah just
like and I like just looking fast like
this is something with me now I know
well if you're in the props warehouse
you've got it just like get as much
stuff as you can and don't take anything
as I'm sure they'll they'll find you why
do I to kind of do I might I would want
like a like a black panther glove and
there are ten years of films worth of
props that shoot around and that's the
coolest thing about it it's like the
props have such an important part in the
storytelling of these movies like with
Peter Quill's blasters and the reload
thing and it's just I can I could go
down to the props wormhole forever I
know and there's just there's so much
history from the 10 years of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe if only there was a
way to test that knowledge there is
Laraine
there in fact very much is I actually
had the chance to catch up with people
on the street to test their MCU
knowledge brought to you by Walmart
Marvel Studios Avengers infinity war is
out now so I'm gonna see if some of
these people on the streets of New York
City know enough about the Avengers to
win some awesome prizes so I'm gonna ask
you free trivia questions you get them
right you can win a prize sound good all
right
Peter quill is also known as star little
star-lord yeah sure is the destruction
of this fictional European city led the
call for you and oversight over the
Avengers Asarco Pru crane no fiction
that's a repo I know it was sokovia
sorry what mythical land does for hail
from a scar yeah what nation in the MCU
is known as the most technologically
advanced in the world sure is well Conda
yeah I'll give you a rhyme and you have
to tell me who this rhyme is about okay
okay you'll lose if you fight her this
hero is named after a spider Oh No
you gave me a hard one it starts with
the color that's what a color no because
you got all three right you are gonna
get this
there are no losers here at Marvel so
you are gonna get a code for a free
month of comics from Marvel unlimited
thank you sounds great awesome yeah
thank you thank you enjoy you know what
these people did what they do these
people did great yeah congratulations
you know everyone you know a lot more
about the MCU than you think you do so
hey remember that have faith in yourself
and you know if you want to know more
about the Marvel Comics universe you
should go check out free comic book day
on may 5th that's this Saturday it's
free comic book day which means if you
go into a comic book store that is
participating you can get a free comic
yes you can get a free amazing
spider-man calm that's always great cuz
people love spider-man and adventures
comics some that's kind of cool
about what's gonna happen in the Marvel
Comics universe in those comics so you
should go pick them up
teases and secrets I like it well tell
us what you guys thought of the show
today and our incredible clip from
Marvel Studios Black Panther extras and
a hashtag or lady shot
yeah we'll see you next time all right
and I'm like this is your universe or
click that box over there to watch our
last episode so what are you gonna steal
from the props warehouse I think I'm
going to take 20 stars race card I'll
see how far you get before I run out of
gas pretty for for the cops